[Aplausos]
qué es lo primero que piensas cuando
escucha la palabra futuro
acaso te has puesto a pensar alguna vez
en el futuro
estoy seguro que cuando piensas en ello
visualizas máquinas super poderosas
capaces de realizar cualquier actividad
de nuestra vida cotidiana
es probable que hayas imaginado
tecnología super avanzada de última
generación
probablemente vino a tu cabeza que
conquistamos el planeta marte los más
aventurados quizás imaginaron una
especie de humanoide algo así como
sacado de una película de ciencia
ficción
hoy te vengo a hablar del único futuro
que puedo garantizarte si es que no
mueres antes la vejez
y es que difícilmente pensamos en la
vejez como una posibilidad
estamos condicionados a vivir en el aquí
y en el ahora que no nos ponemos a
pensar en el futuro es más a veces hasta
pensamos que es prohibido imaginarnos lo
y pensar en ellos tan importante como
estar respirando en este momento
cuando yo inicie la carrera de medicina
era un chavo de 18 o 20 años que tampoco
pensaba en ello
durante toda mi formación académica como
médico me interesa ir a especializarme
en pediatría el otro extremo de la vida
es más los programas académicos de todas
las facultades de medicina de este país
no contemplaban la materia de geriatría
nadie pensaba en eso no era atractivo
pensar en ello
hoy puedo decirte y puedo hablarte de lo
hermoso que es la vejez y lo digo así
hermoso con todas sus letras y te lo
puedo decir porque yo he enfrentado
todos los días de mi vida
es cierto no soy un viejo no soy un
anciano no soy un adulto de la tercera
edad pero día a día me enfrento a casos
en donde puedo describir perfectamente
lo que es la vejez
no todo fue fácil en un inicio a mí me
tocó presenciar actos y escenarios tan
terroríficos como si fueran sacados de
un episodio de una novela de víctor hugo
casos de abandono casos de maltrato
casos de maltrato físico maltrato
psicológico pobreza enfermedad por
supuesto
y lo peor del caso es que nadie se
interesaba por ello
a nosotros nos tocó picar piedra para
poder ingresar los programas académicos
con una materia de geriatría
méxico es un país que al igual que el
resto del mundo está cambiando
demográficamente hablando cada vez somos
más viejos o vamos a ser más viejos en
comparación a las personas adultas
jóvenes o los niños actualmente en
nuestro país existen 12 millones de
adultos mayores eso representa el 10 por
ciento de nuestra población es como si
juntáramos a todas las personas de los
estados de sonora chihuahua y coahuila
al mismo tiempo y en el mismo lugar
significaría entonces que el 10% de los
recursos que tenemos como país deben de
estar destinados para el beneficio de
los adultos mayores así por ejemplo
cuando vamos a un centro comercial
cuando vamos al banco cuando vamos al
súper simple y sencillamente caminar por
nuestras calles el 10% de la
infraestructura que está en estos
lugares debe estar enfocada para la
movilidad de los adultos mayores y yo te
pregunto es así
por supuesto que no
otra de las cosas que me llama mucho la
atención no me llamó mucho la atención
es una vez que fui involucrando me
además con la vida de mis pacientes y no
solo enfocarme en el problema de salud
sino que me fui enfoque incluyendo o
metiendo en sus vidas personales y
particulares yo les preguntaba a mis
pacientes qué opinas acerca de la vejez
tú tú que si estás en la vejez tú que en
este momento eres una persona adulto
mayor qué opinas te duele te entristece
te frustra que sientes dímelo cuéntamelo
y más allá de muchas respuestas que
obtuve existía un denominador común
entre todos ellos y ese denominador
común era algo tan sencillo como lo
siguiente
lo único que estoy arrepentido es de no
haber hecho todas esas cosas que pude y
no me atreví
lo único que me gustaría cambiar es
aquellas cosas que tenía puestas en
bandeja de plata y por alguna razón no
me atreví a hacerlas
lo único que me duele es no haber
pensado que en algún momento de mi vida
iba a llegar aquí
no sé qué acaban de enfermedades no se
quejaban de pobreza no se quejaban de
nada de eso eventualmente en algún
momento todas esas situaciones mermaban
suscitó su condición de bienestar pero
lo más importante era eso todas las
cosas que pudieron desarrollar y no se
atrevieron a hacer
no esperes a tener 70 años para pensar
que estás envejeciendo
tú estás envejeciendo desde el primer
día de tu vida
todos los días miles de células están
cambiando en tu cuerpo una nación y
otras mueren
tú no eres el mismo de ayer tú estás
envejeciendo aquí y ahora
y te invito a que lo hagas pero con
sentido
que aquí y ahora tomes todas las
funciones y acciones para que si tienes
la oportunidad de llegar a la vejez lo
hagas con sentido
no esperes a tener más de 40 años para
darte cuenta que las rodillas existen
solo porque te duelen
no esperes atender arrugas en tu cara no
esperes a tener canas en tu cabello
no esperes a vivir condicionado por un
medicamento indicado por tu médico
el resto de tu vida para poder llevar
una vida saludable tranquila
es verdad es aquí y ahora
es aquí y ahora pero con un objetivo que
si todo sale bien y la historia natural
de tu vida sigue vas a enfrentarlo en
algún momento
es aquí y ahora donde yo te invito a que
comas bien a que duermas a que descanses
a que formes un grupo de amigos sólidos
que son los que van a ayudarte cuando
seas un viejo
elementos de un envejecimiento exitoso
es aquí en donde yo te invito pues a que
cambies tu manera de pensar
no te estoy pidiendo que vivas
angustiado pensando en el futuro
tampoco te estoy pidiendo que vivas
deprimido echando un vistazo hacia atrás
vivir aquí y ahora es como si
condujéramos un coche
tu coche tu palanca de velocidades tu
volante de tus direccionales es aquí es
el presente vas conduciendo
sin embargo todo el mundo tenemos un
espejo retrovisor al cual le echamos un
vistazo de vez en cuando y miramos hacia
atrás hacia el pasado
y por supuesto también tenemos un
objetivo o un destino al cual queremos
llegar ese es nuestro futuro
las tres cosas deben de estar
equilibradas al mismo tiempo
no te creas eso de no voltear hacia
atrás y no angustiarse por el futuro
las tres cosas deben de estar al mismo
tiempo la vejez después es como un lujo
que no todos se pueden dar la vida
la vejez pues es como correr un maratón
puedes no llegar a la meta
puedes llegar desfalleciendo te y
sufriendo
o puedes llegar con los brazos arriba en
señal de júbilo todo depende de cómo te
hayas preparado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]